so as we get into flashpoint part three
what we do here is we backtrack for a
second and we're going to cover the
story of Wonder Woman and the Furies now
this particular story gives us the
events or at least one part of the
events that led up to the conflict
between Wonder Woman and Aquaman but
more so than that it tells us why Europe
is in such disarray now Dan Abnett was
the one that gave us the story and he
actually did in a really really good way
he did a really awesome job with helping
us come to grips with everything that's
happened so far what we're told is that
with Arthur curry at a young age instead
of falling in love with Meera and
marrying her as his queen instead he had
met Wonder Woman now the two of them is
images met each other by virtue of their
own adventure and their own celebration
and in truth this is basically Dada aDNA
telling us that Arthur curry is the
stand-in for Steve Trevor instead of tea
Steve Trevor being the first man that
when a woman meets and eventually falls
in love with instead she ends up falling
in love with Arthur curry now they're
both attacked by sea monster or at least
she's attacked by sea monster and Arthur
curry comes to her rescue but because of
the fact that she is a character that
you know is strong in her own right with
regards to being on new Themis Keira and
because the Atlanteans don't usually
deal with surface dwellers in a lot of
ways their love was kind of forbidden it
was a very Romeo and Juliet sort of
situation in the sense that instead of
it being their parents who were against
the the union between Wonder Woman and
Aquaman instead it was actually a couple
people it was Artemis on the from from
new famous Kira and it was Aquaman's
mother or who were against this now in
terms of why they were against this and
why they instigated this war in the
first place this will be covered as we
get further into flashpoint suddenly
because I don't want to give certain
things away but the fact remains that
both Artemis and Orem had instigated
what appeared to be an assassination on
Wonder Woman at the hands of an
Atlantean and so a spear was thrown and
Queen Hippolyta had basically seen this
spear coming at her daughter and dived
in the way the result was that she had
died and in return
Wonder Woman believed that it was an
Atlantean now this is later on revealed
to actually be Artemis herself who had
thrown the spear and Aqualad had stepped
in I guess you know the sidekick you
know Garth the sidekick of Aquaman had
discovered what was going on but in the
confrontation he was effectively killed
you know when he
was thrown off a balcony and so with the
body of Garth showing up here when the
went because Artemis had not been found
in the end it was believed by the
Amazons that the Atlanteans were
engaging in war they were attempting to
use this union between Arthur Currie and
Wonder Woman as a means to subvert the
mascara and take it over in its entirety
and so the result is that the the
Atlanteans are kicked off the island and
the Amazons begin the process of going
through the traditional three-day ritual
to mourn the loss of their Queen now
this puts both Aquaman and Wonder Woman
in a tough situation because in truth
they are king and queen first and their
hero second and what I mean by that is
throughout their entire history really
more so with Aquaman than with Wonder
Woman Aquaman has always been in a
situation where if it came down to the
fact that Atlantis was being attacked
and the Justice League was being
attacked at the same time he would
choose Atlantis over Justice League
almost every single time just because
he's a king first and he's a hero second
with Wonder Woman it was never really
the same way traditionally she would
always stand up for the mascara but she
always recognized that her role was more
significant to the world than it was to
her people and so she was always in a
tough situation because she routinely
had to choose between her own people and
you know the I guess the earth as a
whole as humanity and the relationships
that she had fours alongside the other
members of the Justice League in
flashpoint
it's not that way because the fact that
she is now the Queen but because of the
fact that the perception is the
Atlanteans are trying to wage war and
trying to take over the mascara her
loyalty is entirely to her people
especially considered the fact that the
Justice League does not exist here and
so because of this during this morning
phase she's constantly getting you know
receiving words of poison from Artemis
at the same time you know Aquaman is
constantly receiving words are poison
for his brother arm and they're
basically ceding conflict between the
two of them their seating war between
the two of them now again they're not
necessarily wanting to do this and what
ends up happening here is Aquaman
actually travels to the mascara for the
purpose of trying to mend this rift
between the two of them it's really an
olive branch trying to make the case
that yes
the death of Queen Hippolyta was very
tragic but it was not committed by
Atlanteans there's something else going
on here
but because the Amazons are in a state
of grief because virtually all of them
except for Artemis are unaware of the
fact that it was actually a ploy that
was going on that is designed to be a
ruse Artemis basically calls in an
attack she calls in a huge conflict
between the Atlanteans and the Amazons
and the result is that again in the eyes
of Wonder Woman the Atlanteans are
engaging and yet another instance of
treachery and so because of the fact
that the Atlanteans seem to be winning
the war because of the fact that Wonder
Woman is not aware of Artemis sabotaging
the Amazons themselves to make it look
like the the Atlanteans are winning in
the end
Wonder Woman makes the case that they
need to abandon release she's kind of
forced in a position to abandon famous
Kira to blow up the island and take
refuge elsewhere and this is exactly
what she does she basically sets off the
Argus releases the restraints that are
normally used in famous Kira and allows
it to explode now what I mean by this as
those of you guys who don't know and at
least it's really cool because it's
given to us by Dan Abnett as he gives us
his explanation the famous Kira lives it
exists on a on a volcano and the Amazons
harnessed the geothermal energy of this
volcano in order to provide what they
need for survival the result is that
restraints are needed in order to keep
the volcano from going active and
exploding what Wonder Woman did is she
removed these restraints and so as the
Atlanteans are fleeing for dear life the
the island is exploding all around them
now from here Dan Abnett fast-tracks a
few things he actually gives us
information from the eyes of a reporter
named Jack Ryder and what he tells us is
that after the destruction of the
mascara its remaining citizens took off
in fleets and they basically went to
Europe they went to to the United
Kingdom to England as refugees they
looked to England to house them to give
them a place to stay temporarily until
they could reform the mascara the
problem is that England said no and so
Wonder Woman decided to take it by force
she literally launched an invasion of
England she resented herself to
Parliament and said and basically
justified her case saying that we are in
need of a home your home is as good as
any it now belongs to us and this
basically gives us a darker side of
wonder 1 but it also tells us even
indirectly behind-the-scenes that maybe
everything that she's doing isn't things
that she wants to do she's doing them
because she asked will if you to her
people her goal is to make sure that the
mascara has a home and if that home
means taking the home of somebody else
then that's what she will do as a result
she also began gathering some of the
most powerful women and DC comics around
her calling them the Furies now this is
basically Dan Abnett paying a little bit
of a tribute to the history of Wonder
Woman in the sense that the Furies are
actually an organization or a group that
exists under Darkseid and is composed of
his most powerful women they are forced
to be reckoned with and it was actually
a story where Wonder Woman was inducted
into the Furies against her will for a
time and so this is basically Dan
Abbott's saying that even if we're not
going to see Darkseid even if we won't
see his Furies we will see some tribute
to the concept of the Furies themselves
now while this is going on no while this
conflict is taking place we pick back up
with Aquaman and again he's being put in
a hard and a hard spot here he's being
put in a situation where he's being
asked to do things that he doesn't
really want to do the idea is that
because of the fact that the Amazons
have wiped out Thomas Kira because they
have engaged in war because both
Atlantis and Amazon's are at war with
one another the idea is that the
Atlanteans need to repay in kind they
need to do something to show the Amazons
that they are not to be pushed around
they cannot simply be walked over and so
the idea is to basically lay waste to
the mascara by destroying England and so
while Aquaman doesn't want to do this he
also asked a question where his wife
Mira is located and so what we do is we
switch to the Port of Dover in England
in new Themis Kyra and what happens is
Mira makes her presence known Mira
basically attacks the Amazons along with
a host of Atlantean soldiers now while
the Atlantean soldiers are holding their
own against the Amazons Mira and Wonder
Woman engage in a fight with one another
and when they do the fight is actually
pretty Swift there's really not much of
a contest here Wonder Woman comes out on
top and she cuts off the head of Mira
and because of this because Mira is now
you know or at least because she was
betrothed to Aquaman he takes this as
the utmost threat he takes this as
something that cannot be called back and
so he effectively declares open war on
the Amazons for the first time in the
midst of this conflict and in doing so
orders the entire sinking of year
at the hands of the Atlanteans
superweapons having said that as we
continue our discussion with the main
flashpoint story itself we pick back up
again with Thomas Wayne and Barry Allen
now I do apologize if I keep saying
Bruce Wayne incidentally it's just I'm
not used to saying Thomas Wayne Batman
it kind of throws me off kilter whenever
I have to say that I kind of have to
pause and make sure that I didn't
actually say Bruce Wayne but if I happen
to do that in the future these videos
don't hold it against me it's just it's
something I'm not used to saying Thomas
Wayne Batman it's just kind of crazy to
me but that's one of the reasons why the
story is so cool because it just gives
us different depictions of characters
that we've come to know and love and so
with Barry Allen having been
electrocuted due to the fact that he was
trying to get his powers back the
lightning storms simply just frying his
body where Thomas Wayne takes him back
to the Batcave tries to nurse him back
to health in the end Barry Allen wants
to try again now from the perspective of
Thomas Wayne this is absolutely crazy
because in his mind a guy just showed up
on his doorstep said he was the fastest
man alive
God has powers that way because he was
dealt with chemicals that electrocute it
and when he tries to repeat the process
he just ends up getting fried again but
because of the fact that Barry Allen
seems to have information on the way
things are supposed to be he can't help
but believe Barry he can't help but
believe that if there's a single chance
that Bruce Wayne lives instead of dies
that he has to help him here now again
what Geoff Johns also does is he reminds
us that things are beginning to fracture
the things are beginning to change that
because of the fact that this new
reality is totally different in the
sense that Abin sewer is the Green
Lantern instead of Hal Jordan which of
you guys are interested I can do the
story whatever happened to Hal Jordan uh
because the fact that these memories are
beginning to fragment that Geoff Johns
is reminding us they're on a timetable
here the time's running out that they
have to hurry up and this is basically
Barry Allen giving us this information
saying that time is running out they
have to do something and so in order for
for Bruce Wayne to live in order for
things to be turned back to normal you
know Thomas Wayne has to help Barry get
his powers back and so what they do is
they go right back to the rooftop again
and they go through the process of
dousing Barry and chemicals yet again
and when Barry is electrocuted this time
it works and his powers of the flash are
restored to him and so what happens is
that while Barry is recovering because
the fact that his powers of the flash
grant him enhanced healing in the sense
that he can recover from you know flesh
injuries much faster than a normal human
can we transition to new Themis Kiera in
London and we pick up with Lois Lane
now this is actually really cool because
this is basically Geoff Johns beginning
the early stages of rolling you know
Wildstorm characters non main DC
characters over into diesel DC's
landscape those you guys you don't know
um
DC Comics is only one facet of the that
big side of the comic-con we've got
Wildstorm you've got vertigo which is
their adult oriented imprint you've got
a lot of different different characters
at Hale from that side of the spectrum
you know under the larger umbrella of DC
and the purpose to the new 52 was to
take those characters and roll them over
into a single continuity and this is
exactly what Geoff Johns is doing during
this entire situation where Lois Lane is
trying to you know get back into contact
with Steve Trevor even though she
doesn't know at the moment that he's
been taken prisoner by the Amazons what
she does is she comes face to face with
the resistance who's led by grifter now
grifter is a wild storm character we
don't really need to go super in-depth
into him again I think what we've said
so far about you know wild storm and so
on is enough to suffice our explanation
but more so than that what this tells us
is that the citizens of England didn't
just roll over it wasn't as though you
know the Wonder Woman showed up invaded
London and it has kind of gave up and
walked away instead there's small
pockets of resistance the problem here
is they're effectively going up against
forces who are wildly powerful Wonder
Woman having power equivalent to that of
Superman and the result is that they
were laid waste to almost immediately
you know England was conquered almost
right off the bat as so they do the best
they're can but to be honest here
they're basically fighting a losing
battle and so what we do is we jump back
to two thomas wayne and he's looking you
know at barry allen because of the fact
that he has enhanced healing because of
the fact that he's recovering from his
injuries extremely fast this gives
credence to the argument he's been
making that things are not the way
they're supposed to be and so what barry
allen does is he uses his super speed he
grabs different chemicals and so on and
so forth and he makes a new flash
costume super fast which isn't really
supposed to be something significant
here it's just sort of geoff johns
giving us that you know yes things are
getting back on track yes the story is
moving forward yes we're going to start
seeing things return to a state of
normalcy
sort of moment kind of the the tipping
point so to speak of the story at this
point where things are going to start
transitioning in favor of everyone and
so the one question Barry Allen has is
where is Superman because Superman is
the one character who could literally
change the entire tide of battle
Superman can go toe to toe with Aquaman
and Wonder Woman and defeat them both as
well as give humanity something to
aspire to and so as question as a
Superman's not here then where is he did
he simply just not arrive on the planet
Earth this rocket never show up here and
so both he and Thomas Waynes start going
through old footage and we actually get
some really cool explanation here on a
couple things one of the things that
Jeff John shows us or tells us is that
at some point in the past
Kyle Jordan had piloted an experimental
test plane the reason why this matters
is because that's how Joe Hal Jordan
became the Green Lantern originally he
was piloting a test plane he was chosen
by the ring of the dying evidence or and
he was inducted into the Green Lantern
Corps the rest is history
Geoff Johns doesn't really give us any
more than this again this is covered in
a in a tie and but but we're also told
is that there the rocket of Superman did
crash land in Metropolis and so again
Barry Allen tells Thomas Wayne the
Superman is the most powerful person on
the planet and so if they can find
Superman assuming that he's here if they
can locate him and assuming he's not a
bad guy have him fight on their behalf
they can quite literally save the world
and so while Thomas Wayne says that he
doesn't know where Superman is he knows
a person who does and so we picked up
with Barry Allen and Thomas Wayne
meeting with cyborg who again is working
on behalf of the US government and he
has access to all their information and
so what he says is yes he will help them
find Superman but only under the
condition that they fight alongside him
in trying to take back the world and so
what they do is they transition to new
metropolis and when they get there they
basically travel to a military base
under ground and this military base has
been in existence since Superman first
arrived on earth once they get there and
they open up this giant room they find
Superman but he's nothing like the one
that we know instead he's emaciated
he's very thin and he seems like a
normal human being now the reason why
this happened and we can actually kind
of skip over the tie in a little bit
here the reason why this happened was
because when Superman first arrived
instead of being discovered by the
Kent's and instead of being adopted and
taken under their wing where he would
eventually become
you know Clark Kent and eventually
become Superman instead he was
immediately taken by the federal
government and when he was he was held
in stasis with red light which kept his
powers from emerging because he never
experienced the Yellow Sun he's lived
his entire life underground inside this
bunker being held as a prisoner and
being used for experimentation and so
once they break in once they free
Superman this is strange to him because
he's never seen people like this before
he's never seen people like him but more
so than that or Barry Allen this is wild
because he'd never seen his Superman
that looks like this before he's always
seen a huge confident wildly powerful
Superman and so while they're trying
while both you know Superman and Barry
Allen and the heroes are trying to come
to grips with the situation
the soldiers break in and they basically
begin the process of running them off
and so while they escape while they are
able to get out the Superman comes in
the contact with the Yellow Sun for the
very first time and he of course begins
to fly he starts showing his display of
powers but he's not in control here he's
not he doesn't have total control over
his heat vision he doesn't have control
over his flight he's learning these
things for the very first time now he
masters them pretty fast at least in
terms of his ability to fly but he
basically when he's asked by you know by
thomas wayne when he's asked you know to
basically say them to get them out of
there he takes off and he immediately
heads out for the sun and so as this
issue comes to an end were basically
left with cyborg thomas wayne and barry
allen at the at the wrong hand of guns
from u.s. soldiers and it seems as
though they're about to be taken
prisoner so with that being said let me
know what you guys think about this
series so far again I love flashpoint
this is such a well told story I hope
I'm doing it justice I really I really
do um it is a it's a really really good
series and I hope you guys are getting a
lot out of it but yeah without me he
said let me know what you guys think
down in the comments section and I will
catch you guys on him peace
you
[Music]